you're a football fan yes I love it yeah
I'm a dude yeah I love sports you seem
like a dude I'm a bro
yeah technically I'm a bro dude you're a
Brody yeah yeah but I love football
i watch it every Sunday I was watching
it last Sunday have you guys have you
seen the commercial for Lincoln with
Matthew McConaughey yes yeah I don't
you've seen it but it's him giving a
long monologue as he drives my theory is
that he did not know that it was a
commercial buddies and he just said
those words like he's driving his
friends he's like laughs I rode and you
got to drive it and his friends just
were like took out an iPhone and just
they said to him hey we want to make
this a commercial and you'll get paid
millions and he's like oh yeah you
you've worked with him right I have I
don't I wouldn't say we're best friends
no no we work together great guys super
nice fun uneasy didn't he's done him
down yeah he played the owner or the
scout for the Texas Rangers great guy
and I met him and he was like what's up
man I'm Matt nice to meet you and I was
like oh we actually worked together
before I was an extra in rain of fire
which is a film where he fought dragons
in the future and I was not in that
movie at all I'm just a dick I just kind
of said to him I was in yeah I was an
extra he's like oh I remember you how
you been
and I was like I'm just kidding I wasn't
in that film he's like I know like the
wider yeah I know that I was just that's
awful awful and he was so like he's I
don't do that man and I was like I know
[Applause]
my full event lied to like Santa Claus
because he's so nice you know but he
does this thing like you'll be talking
to him and he'll be like are you from
Chicago huh yeah that's a great town man
you know it's all about the people there
you'll start doing like exercise yes
that's like if I saw you as like Conan
so how's your daughter very strange
you